here are the 31 most satisfying moments
in all of board games taking someone out
with the slide and sorry finally landing
on the color you need to complete your
trivial pursuit pie picking up a wild
draw 4 and uno and realizing okay now i
can relax a little getting out of the
molasses swamp and candyland getting the
mousetrap guy to dive into the bucket
that's the hardest part of the whole
trap which is really saying something
not even playing connect four just
filling the board with pieces and
letting them all go at once spelling a
dirty word in scrabble getting a good
spin on the old ice spinner popping that
pop-o-matic bubble shaking up the boggle
cube rolling any dice with more than six
sides not waking daddy doing this with a
guess who board just humiliating a child
at hungry hungry hippos discovering the
movie clue is for some reason actually
pretty amazing swiping your card in ball
madness crossfire crossfire crossfire
buzzing the ever loving out of your
buzzer in taboos swapping out your
soldiers for cannons and risks queen f6
to bishop's rook just kidding i don't
know anything about chess those first
few minutes of twister when every call
is basically just bend over and put your
hand on the floor punching the new
pieces out of a game yahtzee cutting off
someone's longest run contend learning
to tan well enough that you understand
why that's so satisfying finding other
people who want to play dominion just
plain up old school at girl
talk not losing a jenga anytime you get
to jump more than once in checkers when
your friend is a slide down a big ass
shoot getting through a turn in
operation but the number one most
satisfying thing in all of board games
is convincing your friends it is time to
stop playing monopoly